hello hi everyone welcome to thumbtack
before that I give you guys a very brief
introduction of myself my name is
William John I graduated from University
of Illinois in Tucson the Tao and then I
joined Twitter and as a software
engineer as well as data scientist and I
left Twitter in October 2014 and joined
untaek as a software engineer so yeah
welcome here today I will give a brief
discussion about mingling something
about my PhD thesis and a little bit of
my current work which are always highly
related to the machine learning stuff
this is actually brief like skeleton of
my PhD defense and that presentation
cost me three hours and I shrink the
pawn point to like this 10 minutes thing
so I think it's not that easy try to bet
you know my work but it's good to go my
topic will be clustering and comparing
information extracted from personal
health messages so my research interest
focusing on data mining machine learning
and an LP on specifically medical
informatics area we see a lot of online
communities recently in the healthcare
domain for example Web MD Yahoo health
and wellness
discussed group and also met help
patients like me this kind of very good
web sites and communities offered users
customers patients especially doctors a
very good platform and price for them to
communicate with each other or to grab
useful medical informations for your
information need but there are always a
lot of challenges for these discussions
for online communities first this kind
of information are very noisy contains
on useless stuff and also compared with
the real medical records this kind of
messages are pretty unstructured which
is very difficult for people to digest
and the third thing is this kind of
online personal messages are kind of
lack of connection with the real
clinical practice however the
challenger's makes the researchers have
an opportunity to effectively analyze
and reorganize the rich source of
personal health messages by applying
advanced data mining or IR and ARP
techniques how here is some of the
summary summarization of my work I try
to define this whole project or the
whole problem into three different
layers the first layer is data the data
we look at which contains the very rich
personal medical information messages
are coming from a lot of different
channels especially some of the voice
messages and the other is the object we
try to research on there are be full
kind of texts or some of the drug
information disease information or even
the symptom description and also others
of the like techniques we are trying to
apply and I know like most of them are
very related to the machine learning
however is just not the foulest so for
my PhD topics is like I combined three
of the things together like the first
problem I try to solve it is personal
message of classification which applies
yahoogroups health and wellness data
using the classification technology and
analyze the whole text and the second
problem I try to solve is the patient
drug outcomes information which use
additional sources some of the topic
modeling and clustering techniques and
combine some of the drug information
that medicine information
and the third topic we're talking is the
CER hypothesis prediction so you are
maybe you guys not really familiar with
this term it's a medical term called
comparative effectiveness research which
is a medical area is very important
topic try to compare different
treatments or different medications on
the same person or the same group of
people to see which one has a better
effect to which one has a better
performance and a comparative
effectiveness and the other sides and we
use the Med help and other disease
information and also using the semantic
analysis static testing and opinion
mining techniques and also there are
some areas and data I didn't touch to
but I know some of my phone falling HD
friends and a school I'm still working
out that they kind of using some of the
voice messages and they try some of
those social network analysis there
could be the future directions so next I
will just quickly go through the story
topics of three problems I solved the
first is multi-class classification in
online personal health messages we try
to understand and I try to get the
useful information from online personal
messages however some some of them are
kind of useless and we know we want
giving a set of they're like medical
messages we try to separate them into
three main categories the first one is
the news is about the latest information
like some some news about some of the
progress of the treatment that kind of
information is part of important but it
is not the thing we really want we try
to see the personal information so the
second one user comments which will be
our target and third one is a spam which
mostly end with
Iceman's the approach is like with
chewing a multi-class SVM classification
um set off the training data using the
combination features for example the
term appearance and the lexical and
symmetrical features we train our
classification work very carefully and
get 93% of accuracy so I think the main
part main training part is try to get
the feature set so that is the first
work I did and second one called
designing and evaluating in a class
class rating system for integrating
patient drug outcomes so I think it's
kind of long topic but I just try to
explain a little bit for example every
day you go to online like communities
you want to find some of the track or
some of the medicine you want to see how
good it is and right now the most thing
you can do is try to scan and try to
read each piece of messages one by one
it is very inefficient however if we
have a way to integrate all these drugs
into some of the aspects to see people's
opinions of that for example for for
aspirin if you want to take aspirin as a
consideration for got a headache I want
to know like a people's opinions on
aspirins usage am i a good fit on that
or I want to see people's like opinions
on like a Springs like pre pre cultures
what things I need to care about and
treat treatment dosage as well as maybe
side effects all these kind of aspects
if there is kind of summarized
information we can extract from a bunch
of the personal messages which should be
very effective
so my work can be summarized by this
graph first we have the Yahoo messages
which organized by each specific job
and we do the previous classification I
will separate them into news spam and
user comment and we sleep we eliminate
the news and spam because there is not
we really want and after that we do
refine an extraction put some of the
useful sentences from the user comment
here another kind of machine learning
text our life is like we should figure
out what kind of sentences from the user
comments are useful and a woman's
sentences are not useful so we train
another model to clarify and we get a
lot of common units the collection based
on some of the experts as for comments
coming from the met PubMed health as the
seat between semi-supervised clustering
system using the POS a topic model and
get outcome integration separation get
our results just as I said giving a
specific drug we will summarize each
drug outcome in two different aspects
totally usually is maybe eight to twelve
depends on the size of it depends on the
numbers of the clusters and for each
cluster
which represent one aspects of people's
opinions on top of this kind of job
maybe it's about the side effects we
will see people's different opinions and
we offer another inactive system
interface so user you can have in some
of the job you want and you can take a
look at instruct and you don't really
need to read all these messages you just
read you just need to read the summary
and then you have your judgment at the
same time we asked to verify our system
we have asked some of the medical school
students to be the charges and let them
manually label this data and try to
separate each other's messages into
several
as fats and a compare the results use
that as the gonna stand and then compare
with our results it seems like it's very
consistent so the outcomes for that is
first a we have very high performance to
cluster patient outcomes using semi PRSA
model the second one is is very
interesting this is kind of extra bonus
we found we found some very unknown
outcome unknown extra like aspects for
example this medicine I don't know how
to read it I know but I forgot may help
to relieve the burning mouth syndrome
which is you can you is kind of
impossible for you to get this
information read by read one by one like
messages but we found that and we got
disproved by one of the medical
professional magazine and also we offer
a very comprehensive evaluation
framework who is the medical students so
let's talk about the third project I'm
working on it's it's still ongoing
because we're still polishing the paper
but I don't really have that much time
to punch that but this do slowly growing
it's called a comprehensive comparative
effectiveness research hypotheses
prediction so as I said for example if
when we talk about breast cancer there
may be different kinds of treatments
basically we want to ask a question like
chemo and hormonal therapy which one is
more effective and this is the questions
that see our researchers in a medical
area they try to solve so they were
always go through very long term and
very costing clinical trials however
actually people's are pinning a very
important a cell they can
something and they can sell tell the
public they are your home opinions on
these kind of different treatments which
is very easy to achieve and a scalable
so we don't really need to go through
the lung to like medical trials but we
can do this kind of see our prediction
first and then make some pre conclusion
and make the long-term trial - chocolate
- to verify so there will be two main
reasons why we do this first it's like
we can prove some existence in your
conclusions
the second is like try to predict some
unknown see our hypothesis it will be
very effective for the real CER works as
I said the for the real CER if you
really want to know like to compare two
treatments you definitely need the
long-term like the clinical trials but
before that you have many many choices
but try to try you want to try maybe two
of them or three of them and if from our
our word analysis we found maybe for
example treatment a is definitely
doesn't really worse to take a try if it
is our conclusion and it is trustful you
don't really need to waste money and
with time on this kind of treatment
comparison so it could be proof or it
can do the prediction so our source is
coming from man hell which is a very
professional like the medical messages
platform there are a lot of doctors and
amount of patience dear and the discuss
about their symptoms their treatments
advances we choose breast cancer and
depression as our research object
because there are very common disease
which also contains a source for input
for breast cancer we compare chemo
radiation and hormonal therapy and a for
depression would compare the medication
there a versus drug treatments there
were three different trials of the jaw
which is SSRI as an RIT CA I didn't have
depression so I don't know what that's a
mean but there are difference three
different trials the approach is we
definitely want to enough analysis we
definitely want to the analysis of the
preference and the service sentiment
analysis the basic idea is giving a
bench of this kind of messages first we
were chewing up comparison model what is
a conversion model it is forum maybe one
or two paragraphs about maybe one breast
cancer patient she may describe
something about the treatments she have
already taken first we build a model to
said I select all kind of patients who
wrote this kind of message and then took
at least two of the treatments so that
is a comparison right they need to
analyse the chemo and radiation and then
she can do the comparison and so we
should build this kind of model by some
of the training and after that we'll be
extracting the sentences which have the
hint of the comparison which is very
difficult we but we have a large amount
of data so we use we choose maybe thirty
percent of them as a training and we
build out a very good comparison model
which can give us very good outcomes of
all the sentences or paragraphs which
involves comparison
another thing is a semantic model for
example I gave you a sentence saying oh
I like a but I don't like B so there is
a very significant preference saying I
prefer A to B but it's just a very
simple sentence people can have
different kind of ways to say this thing
so we also need another sentiment model
to giving an input and article will be
showing people's preference that also
needs to base out on the training and
our
testing besides that we also do the
demographic analysis which cross
different gender different age and the
location which tries to answer the
question like which treatment works best
for whom okay so here are some results
these we cannot predict the future thing
if something we found here we can
there's no future playing the trial so
we can only do the first thing try to
approve some of the current conclusions
we find the most this is just choose
examples that we found from our research
and then we compare with some of the
like alicent this is a very good like
england medical magazine we find out
improvement which means it's very
consistent to our discussion our
discount discoveries so which means like
personal messages mathematical messages
are really really informational and
machine learning
taxi techniques can help us to discover
to explore to find some very good things
okay that is my the skeleton of my PhD
ceases and i mean take a little more
time to talk about the things i learned
from the industry but my first job was
at twitter and i was in search and a
content team so there are two things i
use machine learning techniques about
one is the i work work for who do follow
team which will give you the whole photo
recommendation giving a user will be
decide what kind of persons you probably
follow so that it's involved this very
like a secret but you can imagine like
we will be kind of like user model and
like people model that and then do
better matching and another thing is i'm
very proud of because i do that by
myself which is the user interest
specifically TV sports detection of the
prediction we're trying to find
whether a user is entreating about TV or
whether or not people interesting about
sports and also we want to tell user
which kind of TV issues they may be
interesting most so we can give more
this kind of TV related or sports
related information tweets to that user
and right now I joined thumbtack and
there are a lot of space for amateur
lemme to do here they are just two
examples first it's like for someone who
don't really familiar with our service
we try to gave the customers the best
practice to find some local services and
the gaming requests and I will find the
pros to help you to finish your project
so there's a question how to do the
better request and pro matching we will
giving requests how to find the best
match the pros that could be solved by
Magellan indexing techniques the other
one is the relevant project
recommendation for example today I hire
a housecleaner
and I finished my job and very satisfied
but sometimes some tech wants you to
come back again and then find other
projects so we may say like a people
like you who hire a hospital er would be
probably maybe hire a DJ or higher maybe
another guy or some of adequate
categories so we try to find this kind
of relevant recommendation which is also
very challenging but could be very
useful so as I said we're sure learning
taxis is everywhere if you really want
to know more you need to explore by
yourself okay that is just my talk and
thank you if you have any other
questions related to my work or related
to my research just email me each organ
I thank you